Um, good morning. So, today we do Joseph
Stalin and I want to make you the
argument that Joseph Stalin is probably
the greatest man who ever lived. Okay,
for three reasons. Uh, the first reason
is that uh Joseph Stalin, he is a uh
poor high school dropout from Georgia,
which is on the fringes of the Russian
Empire. and he leads an extreme fringe
and despised political party called the
Bolsheviks into absolute power in
Russia. Okay, that's the first reason.
Second reason is that um among the
Bolsheviks, Stalin is the least
impressive. Everyone else is um
intellectual with um many books, many
speeches, many achievements uh to his
resume. But Stalin defeats them all and
becomes uh the ultimate ruler of Soviet
uh Russia. The sec second reason. And
the third reason is during World War II
uh Soviet Union was up against Germany.
Um so Stalin took a poor divided
isolated nation and defeated Germany and
turn it into a global hedgeimon. All
right. So these are the three main
reasons why I consider Stalin to be uh
the certainly the greatest man of the
20th century and quite possibly you can
make the argument that he was the
greatest man who ever lived. Okay. So
let me reframe what I just said in a
different way so it's clearer to you.
The Bolshvix should not have triumphed.
Okay. If you just looked at um what's
going on in the um early 20th century in
Russia, you would not have predicted
that the Soviets would have won. Stalin
should not become Soviet leader and the
Soviets should not have won World War
II. All right. All these three things
happen because Stalin willed this
reality into being. He is what Frederick
Nichi would call the urbuts. The urbance
is someone who steps out of outside of
history and warps it to his will. Okay,
that is Joseph Stalin. That is the
argument I will make to you uh today.
All right. So, some basic history about
Russia. Um as we discussed previously
about Russia, Russia um is very much a
nation with a split personality. It is
both Asian as well as European, both
Christian and pagan, both enlightened as
well as reactionary. And because of
these contradictions, it leads to many
rebellions and revolutions throughout
Russian history. One of the most famous
being 1825, a group of military officers
called the December tried to overthrow
the SAR uh and install a military
dictatorship. Um, ever since this event,
uh,
revolutionary the revolutionary uh, um,
discussion becomes sort of like a
national pastime in Russia. uh Dossi um
both DossiKi and Toy Stoy were
sympathetic to uh revolutions.
um 1853 to 1856 is a pivotal moment in
Europe in Russian history because that's
when Russia loses the Crimean War to the
Ottoman Empire backed by the French and
the British and this marks
um a limit to the expansion of Russia.
So one way that Russia resolves its
internal contradictions in its internal
conflicts is by expanding eastwards and
allowing the nobles to accumulate more
land, more slaves and that um um
mllifies a lot of these nobles. But in
1853 and 18 to 1856 after Russia loses
the Korean war, Russia understands that
um it is backward and agricultural
compared with uh Europe. So Alexander II
who is Sar of Russia at this time he
embarks on a series of radical liberal
reforms. The most major being in 1861 he
he emancipates he emancipates the surfs.
The surfs are slaves who are tied down
to the land. Um, and by liberating them,
he hopes to further industrialize Russia
as well as create a more vibrant market
economy, which is what you need to be a
modern uh, nation state. But as you can
imagine, this creates a lot of uh, push
back from the nobles who lose a lot of
wealth and property because of these
reforms. A fun fact about a second was
he was very good friends with Abraham
Lincoln. In fact, uh, Axon II was a huge
admirer of the American Republic. So
much so that when in 1861 the American
Civil War started, um, Sar Alexander the
second was worried that the French and
the British would intervene on behalf of
the Confederacy. The reason why is that
first of all, the uh, American
Confederacy provides a lot of cotton to
the British and the French for their
textile industry as well. um as well the
French and the British see America as a
growing threat. So by supporting the
Confederacy they believe that they can
um divide and weaken America. So in
response as I publicly stated that if
the French and the British ever declare
um an alliance with the Confederacy,
then Russia would intervene on behalf of
the Union. And to show that he was
serious, he sent warships to New York
and San Francisco to show that that
Russia would defend America. Uh so this
is forgotten, but this is a really fun
fact about um uh Russian history that
Axi was a huge admirer of Abraham
Lincoln. They wrote letters to each
other and he did much to uh save the
American Union in a in a time of its in
time of crisis. Um now in 1881 his
liberal reform stopped when he was
assassinated. This was a day he was
assassined on the day that he returned
um u from a meeting where where he
basically he was going to promote
constitutional monarchy in Russia and
then he was assassinated by a terrorist
group called the people's will. Now
there's a very good reason why the
people's will um assassinate um
Alexander the II. At this time in
Russian history there were a lot of
revolutionaries who believed that to
liberate Russia you need to liberate the
mindset of the peasants. The problem is
the mindset love the SAR and they and so
the in intellectuals felt that this the
idea of the SAR enslaved the peasants
from seeking enlightenment and freedom
and therefore to send a signal to
liberate the peasantry you needed to
kill the SAR in an act of violence and
that's what happened in um
1881. Um, so this is the people's will
and what you will see is that they're a
very small group of people. There there
was at most 2,000 and they they were
founded right before they assassinated
as the second 1879 and after
assassination they were all the major
members were quickly arrested by the
secret police and executed and they
confessed to their crimes. That's why we
know so much about them. But this
creates a problem. The problem is this.
If the secret police were so effective
in capturing all the assassins right
after the assassination, why weren't
they effective in stopping the
assassination? That's a curious
question. In fact, if you think about
some more, you have some other problems.
For example, the people's will, it is a
terrorist organization, but where do
they get the funding? All right, this is
always a problem when you are an under
underground organization. Where do you
get your financing from? Another problem
is um if these are religious fanatics,
they really believe that their mission
is to liberate the peasantry. They're
probably very opinionated and it's
probably very hard to organize them into
a hierarchy. All right, so these are two
major problems that the people's will
and other terrorist organizations
throughout Russian history will face
including the bullshiks. Now to answer
both questions, let's do a thought
experiment. Let's just say you're secret
police, okay? and you're tasked with uh
monitoring and capturing these
terrorists. Now, is it to your benefit
to capture them or is it to your benefit
to assist them? All right. Now, this
sounds like a silly question, but let's
think about some let's think about
deeply. All right. So, why don't you
want to support political extremists?
Well, there's some very good reasons.
It's risky. It's violent. It's
unethical. It doesn't really help
anyone. Okay? So, we should not help
political extremists. But if you're
secret
police and you ask yourself what are the
benefits of helping them, it turns out
there's quite a lot. All right, let's go
over them. Number one, by helping
extremists, you defame the entire
political opposition, right? You make
all the people who oppose the SAR look
bad because look, these are fanatical.
They're violent. Okay, that's one really
good reason why you want to support
extremists. Second is you want to
forment internal disscent among
political opponents. Okay, so the
classic example is um the Marxist group
at this time in history are the Mansion
and they are intellectuals and they
believe heavily in Marx. The Bullshiks
are led by Lenin and they are an extreme
group. The main conflict is the manik
believe that for the revolution to
happen you have to follow Marxist
prescription which is you go from an
autocracy to a borchery uh
democracy because that is what's going
to help Russia industrialize. Once
industrialization happens, capitaliz
capitalism will in will automatically
make the proletariat class conscious and
when they're class conscious, they will
unite and overthrow the borch democracy
to to create the dictation of the
politarian. Okay, that is a classical
Marx uh theory of evolution towards a
communist society. Lenin believe no we
don't need this. Okay, because the
mechic worldview is we have to be
patient. We have to wait for u Russia to
industrialize. Right now um the
industrial workers in Russia is about 3%
of the population. Okay, the peasantry
is 80%. And Lenon's argument is we'd
have to wait for the politic become 80%
of the population. What we can do is
create a vanguard party and lead the
peasants into communist paradise. Okay.
And the mesh say when you do that all
you're doing is creating a um peasant
revolution which will lead to a
dictatorship of the peasantry. Okay.
You'll be no different from the zar. All
right. So um eventually Lenin and the
bleviks will split apart from the
manviks. Okay. And it would be to the
benefit of secret police to support the
bolshviks. Right. and and and and of and
we we'll see evidence for this later on.
Um the by supporting political
extremism, you also induce political
violence to justify more state control,
right? Um you collect intelligence by
implanting spies within these extremist
groups. Uh you can also arrest
extremists to score political points
within the bureaucracy, right? Because
the secret police is is getting paid a
lot of money. How how do they justify
their salaries? Well, they arrest
extremists that they support. Okay. Um
also you can use these extremists to to
assassinate political enemies. All
right. So you make the argument that
within the within the secret police
there's a faction of nobles who were
outraged at the reforms of Alexander the
second especially the thought of
creating a constitutional monarchy which
would limit the powers of the of the
aristocracy and therefore they had the
people's will kill um Alexander the
second. You also have false flag
operations where you have extremists um
on behalf of your enemy create terrorist
events within the country which will
justify a war against an enemy. Okay.
And also like the best reason of course
is because it's fun and exciting. All
right. The people in the secret police
they're all psychopaths and they
enjoy this process. Okay. In fact, you
can make the argument that one of the
main functions of the secret police is
to create problems for society so that
they can justify their power. All right?
So again, this sounds pretty extreme to
you, but look at let's look at some
evidence that this is that this was a
case in Russia in the late 19th century.
All right, so this is Vladimir Lennon
and he was a revolutionary who had to
escape to Europe in order to uh not be
captured by the secret police. Okay. And
again, he was a fanatic. So, let's read
from
Wikipedia about his time in London.
Lennon's factionalism began to alienate
increasing numbers of bullshiks,
including his former close supporters.
Okay? So, this guy was an [ __ ] He
was a fanatic. He was extreme. He was
violent. No one liked this guy. And
normally what would happen is he becomes
ostracized. He becomes alienated. He is
thrown aside. And he is left to write
his own books. Okay? which would happen
in a normal course of events. But at
this time in history, the secret police
intervene. The Okina, which is the
Russian imperial secret police, exploit
his factional attitude by sending a spy,
Roman Milanskovski, to act as a vocal
lenorter within the
party. Various Bix expressed their
suspicions about Malansky to Lenin.
Although it's unclear if the latter was
aware of the spies duplicity, it's
possible that he used Malansky to feed
false information to the Ocrana. Okay,
do you understand? The secret police was
a active supporter of Vladimir
Lenin. Now the Wikipedia tells us that
okay well um a sent a spy to support
Lenin, but we can also guess that the
secret police were also sending money to
Lenin, which is very important, right?
because Lenin can support his faction
within the larger socialist movement. In
fact, they probably have more money than
the other groups. Okay, so the secret
police is incubating the
Blevix. All right, let's use an example.
Have you ever asked yourself where
Islamic extremist comes from? So when we
did the Islamic Golden Age, what I what
I said and I still believe today is
Islamist the Islamic Golden Age was a
period of openness and tolerance. So So
what changed? Well, after World War II,
the Americans and the British start to
sponsor Islamic extremism. Okay, this is
pretty well known historically. Why?
There are three three main reasons why.
The first reason is at this time in
history, the Soviet Union and America
was fighting a cold war.
There were no Islamic minorities within
America. But guess what? There are lots
and lots of Islamic minorities within
the Soviet Union. Okay? In fact, it was
maybe like a third of the population.
That's a lot. And they hated the
communist because the communists were
atheists and they want to celebrate
their religion. Okay? So by uh
sponsoring Islamic Islamic extremism,
you are destabilizing Soviet Union.
Okay? That's the first really good
reason. Second reason is um at this time
the Middle East is growing in importance
because of its um oil resource right
well at this time in history the 50s
60s7s nationalism terrorism and
socialism are the major ideologies of
these nations at this time and these are
all threats to American British
commercial interests within the Middle
East right because all these idealistics
are saying like we shouldn't give our
oil for free to American and Britain, we
should protect our resource. So by
supporting Islamic extremism, you're
undermining these ideologies, which is
exactly what happened in Iran, right?
And the last reason is um the Americans
and the British heavily support the
Saudi regime, which is extremely
unpopular. So a long time ago, the
Saudis made a pack with Wahhabism, which
is a um fanatical ideology within Islam.
And so by supporting Islamic extremism,
you support Wahhabism which supports the
Saudi regime. Okay? So I want you guys
to remember this. The secret police
throughout history, they've been
supporting local extremists in order to
achieve short-term um political
objectives. Okay. All right. Let's
continue. Um so after the death of Axon
the second, his son Axon the third comes
into power and he is a reactionary. Um
but he dies fairly young which leaves
his son uh Nicholas II to take the
throne. And Nicholas II he's very young
and he's very inexperienced. He's a nice
guy. He loves his family but he's not
really equipped to lead Russia in a time
of tremendous political and social
tomalt. Um
1904 the Russians lose a war against the
Japanese. And at this time, not only do
they lose the war, but there's famine
going on throughout Russia. So, this is
a time of tremendous discontent and
revolution in Russia, which leads to
something called the bloody Sunday in
1905 where worker protesters were killed
by uh soldiers. All right.
Um also at this time what's happening is
that the royal family um they start to
ally themselves with a priest named
Gregory Rasputin. All right. If he looks
scary it's because this is a very scary
man. Um he styles himself as a mystic
and the royal family they have exactly
one hair to the throne and his name is
Alexi the young son. The problem with
Alexi is he has something called
hemophilia which means that if he bleeds
he could die and Rasputin was very good
at calming down Alexi. So Rasputin
became a member of the royal family
essentially but people the Russian
people hated Rasputin because there were
there's rumors that he was like a sex
maniac and he was he was organizing all
these satanic rituals. Also there was a
very popular rumor that the Rasputin was
sleeping with Alexandra. Okay, the uh
Zar Zorina. And eventually the nobles
will organize and assassinate Rasputin
but not before this entire fear does
tremendous damage to the reputation and
prestige of the royal family.
um world war I breaks out and even
though Rasputin pleaded with the SAR not
to intervene, the SAR did did um declare
war against Germany and now Russia is up
against Germany, the Austrian Hungary
Empire as well as the Ottoman Empire.
And this war is devastating for Russia.
And in
1917, there's a huge uh spontaneous
protest against the SAR. And at this
point, his generals tell him he should
abdicate, which is what he does. And so
now the parliament called the Duma
becomes the provisional government and
they clear a republic. All
right? But they're still at war with
Germany. So what Germany does is it
organizes Lenin to be snowmobile back
into Russia so that he can ferment uh
discontent and rebellion and revolution.
Okay. So Stalin sorry so Lenin was not
just a useful idiot to the Russian
secret police but he was also a useful
idiot to the Germans who wanted to knock
Russia out of the war. When Lenin
returned to Russia, he um tried to
organize a rebellion against a
provisional government because
provisional government still wanted to
stay within the stay in the war and
Lenon wanted to take Russia out of the
war. Lenon called for three things,
okay? Land, peace and bread. And this
was very popular among the
people. Eventually, a pro provisional
government tried to arrest Lenin. he
escaped. Uh but then what happened was
uh the military tried to overthrow the
government and now the provincial
government under Kinsky now re now
requires Lenin to help out and defend uh
the republic against the
military and Lenin is not in any way um
a politician. He's a theoretician. Okay.
And he's fanatical. So let's read a
passage from his book state of
revolution which he wrote at the summer
1917 to understand his thinking. He says
the petty bi democrats he's talking
about uh the provincial government those
shem socialists the the menics who
replace the class struggle by dreams of
class harmony even picture the socialist
transformation in a dreamy fashion not
as the overflow of the rule of the
exploiting class but as the peaceful
submission of the minority to the the
majority which has become aware of its
aims. Okay. So Lenin has absolutely
contempt for all all of his enemies a
violent vitual
contempt. All right. So in 1917 October
Lenin uh orders a coup d'eta against
provincial government and this uh will
eventually lead to something called the
Russian civil war. And at this time in
history, the Bolsheviks are controlling
only some small cities, primarily
Petrograd. But their enemies called the
whites. Okay, the whites are uh former
remnants of the Russian Empire, uh the
aristocrats, the military, they control
most of Russia and it seems like they're
making a huge advance against the
Bolsheviks. Okay. But there are three
things that will conspire to ensure the
Bosiks win. The first thing is the
whites don't actually have a policy for
reform. They don't have they want things
to say they are the way they are and
peasants are hungry. They're landless.
They want peace. Okay. So they lose the
support of the peasants. That's the
first problem. Second thing is the um
the Bvigs will enact a reign of terror.
Okay, they have the secret police called
the Czecha which goes around and kills
all enemies of the revolution. Right? So
so they are fanatically installing fear
and terror among the Russian people. The
last reason most important reason is
Leon Trosky. Leon Trosky organizes the
Red Army and Leon Trosky is an
incredible orator as well as organizer.
He is absolutely ruthless. He organizes
uh something called
um blocking division. So the idea is
when you go into battle
um you're supposed to run ahead. If you
if you change your mind, you run back,
someone back a blocker will shoot you to
death. Okay? So it is brutal and but it
works very effectively. Also, um, Leon
Trosky reorganizes the Red Army into a
meritocracy. So, he doesn't care about
your political affiliation. He doesn't
care whether or not you supposed to
support the bullshiks. You're capable.
You'll be promoted within the Red Army.
Okay? So, he turns the Red Army into a
very effective uh fighting force. And
this was what allows the Bolsheviks to
eventually triumph. Okay? So um in many
ways the French Revolution and the
Russian Revolution are very similar
right so let's go over the
similarities in both you have
a poet okay Russo said freedom is
general will Mark said freedom is
classis then you have a prophet who
leads everyone into the promised land
through his peer faith as well as
finanism okay so in the French
revolution you had rose pier who said
reason will set us free. Within the
Russian revolution, you have Lenin who
said violence will set us free. And the
last thing which we'll focus on in this
class is then you have a messiah figure
who comes and he and conquers the world
to ensure the revolution succeeds. Uh in
the French Revolution you have Napoleon
right who said I'm the expanding empire.
Okay. So his theory to ensure the
revolution will survive is to expand
outwards and conquer Europe is which is
what he did. But then you have Stalin
who is I'm the continuous revolution. So
the way that he maintains the the
stability and the vitality of the
revolution is by constantly purging his
enemies. Okay. Very much along the lines
of the cultural revolution in
China. All right. So let's look at the
similarities between Lenin and Pier.
Okay. Both are from the lower nobility.
They're both poets in many ways and
their families face downward mobility.
So Lennon's father was an educator and
member of the low low nobility but but
Lennon's father died when he was young.
Okay. So Lennon and then Lennon's
brother who Lennon really admired he was
arrested while he was at university for
plotting against the empire and he was
and he was executed. Okay. Um but both
are idealists. They sought to create
justice in a world of injustice. Now the
similarities between Napoleon Salon also
really interesting. They're both from
marginalized minorities. Napoleon was
Corsican. sound was Georgian and they
felt persecution inadequacy. Okay. And
so they became obsessed with obtaining
power to escape their insecurities.
Right? So the similarities between these
characters are very very enlightening
for us. All right. So now we focus on
Stalin. All right. Um the background of
Salin is this. His father owned a small
shoe factory when Salin was born. But
then um the father lost the uh factory
and became an abusive
alcoholic. Uh Salin was born was born
poor and um he did well in school. He
had a very loving Christian mother. He
did well in school but in high school he
came in contact with Marxism and then he
dropped out. Okay. So the fact that
Stalin was a young man who suffered
racial discrimination, d mobility, and
an alcoholic father made him the perfect
recruit for three types of
organizations. Criminal networks, uh,
revolutionaries, and the secret police.
And guess what, guys? He was part of all
three networks. And he was a nexus of
these three networks within Georgia.
Okay. All right. So this is Stalin and
he came from a very poor family and
uh eventually he will rise to the very
top. All right. So some Wikipedia uh
background about Salon. Okay. So we
won't read all of it but I I want to
point out some certain sentences. Let's
let's look at this
sentence. He goes to Batuma and there
his milit rhetoric proved divisive among
the city's Marxists. some of whom
suspected he was an agent of Alcatar. He
was a spy. His mission was to um promote
violence and organization within
locality so the secret police can swoop
in and arrest
everyone. And this makes this makes a
lot more sense than a poor man
discoverism and then um uh is totally
committed to the cause. It makes more
more sense that he was recruited as an
spy by secret police in order to sow
discontent and violence among the
Marxists. Okay, let's continue. Silent
began working at the Roths refining
storehouse where he co or co-organized
two worker strikes. After the strike,
leaders were arrested. Okay, really
important. The moment he organized the
strikes, the all these leaders were
arrested. He he co-organized a mass
demonstration which led to the storming
of the prison. Okay. Salon was arrested
in April 1902 and sentenced to three
years exile in Siberia. Arriving in
November 1903. After one failed attempt,
Salon escaped from his exile in January
1904. All right. So throughout this time
he is getting arrested by secret police.
But for the reason he escapes only after
like a month. All right. And the benefit
of being arrested by secret police is
what? He has credentials now. Right? You
can only be a revolutionary if you are
if you've been sent to Siberia by the
secret police. All right. So he so this
is all very suspicious. Okay, let's
continue.
Um in in 1905 government troops
massacred protest Salon was in Baku in
February when ethnic lines broke out
between Armenians and Azeris and he
formed BIC battle squads which he used
to keep the city's waring ethnic
factions apart. So of all the Bolsheviks
okay because at this point in history
Lenin uh Trosky they're basically
writing books. Stalin is the one who's
out there organizing people, committing
violence, uh, creating
organizations. In fact, he's the one
funding the Bullshiks. Okay? Why?
Because he assembles his gang, criminal
network, which attack black hundreds and
raise money through racketeering,
counterfeiting, robberies, and
kidnapping children of wealthy figures
for ransom. He's the main financeier of
the Bolevik party. without him there
would be no BVIS. And I would make the
argument to you that he's doing this on
behalf of the secret police, right?
Because why would you do this? If you're
stealing money, why not keep it for
yourself and spread it to your friends
and bribe the police? Why are you taking
all this money and giving to Lenin,
right? All right. So ultimately, Stalin
will triumph. Why? Because Lenin and
Trosky, okay, his two main competitors
were egoomaniacs who wanted to be proved
right. Okay, they're intellectuals.
They're theorists. Stalin just wants
power for
himself. Okay, so Vladimir Lenin um he
is the um one pushing for the
revolution. He's the theorist, right?
And as the Soviets um develop power um
by the 1920s he's starting to have
strokes. His he's he's he's always been
in bad health, but now he's really in
bad health. And so now he has to figure
out um who will succeed him. Okay. And
ultimately he decides the best person to
succeed him is Leon Trosky because Leon
Trosky he's a hero of the revolution. He
he he like stal sorry he like Lenin both
believe in an international movement of
communism. They both believe that if
communism is to survive in the Soviet
Union that to spread it to Europe. They
both believe very strongly that with one
push because of World War I all of
Europe will fall to communism. Okay.
Stalin disagrees with them though.
Stalin believes in maintaining communism
within the boundaries of the Soviet
Union. Okay. And being a nationalist.
And ultimately it is Stalin who will
triumph over Leon Trosky and Vladimir
Lenin and create his code of personality
in the Soviet Union.
Um most people assume that Stalin and
Lenin were best friends because really
without Stalin there would be no Lenin,
right? But you also make the argument
about Lenin to be no Stalin. Okay? So so
they were codependent on each other. So
it's always assumed that they were best
friends. But before his death, okay, um
Lenin wrote a secret memo to the party
uh leaders and he said this. Comet
Stalin who's now general secretary,
okay, so he's head of the organization
department of the uh communist party
which is which is a very important
position having become secretary general
has unlimited authority cultured in his
hands and I'm not sure whether he will
always be capable of using that
authority with sufficient caution.
Stalin is too coarse and this effect.
What Len is saying is this. If you let
Stalin continue to amass power, he will
become a dictator. Lenin is head of the
or head of the bullshik, but he's not
dictator. There's there's a committee
rule. Okay. So at this point in history,
you would think that okay, Lenin is now
leader and he's going to make it his
mission to ensure Stalin is removed from
the general secretary position and
Stalin is removed as a possible
contender for power over the Soviet
Union. But then something happens which
is Lenin has a stroke, convulsions and
he dies. Okay, we will never know what
really happened. But if you talk to
medical practitioners who've looked at
this case, they say, "Look, these convol
convulsions are more indicative of
poisoning than they are of a stroke."
Okay? So there's certain people, and
this is not a mainstream view. There's
certain people who believe that Salin
poisoned Lenin because Lenin was about
to remove Salin from uh position from
from his position of power. Now, you're
like, "Okay, that makes no sense." But
at this time in history, there are three
individuals that are in the way of
silent amassing complete power. Okay, so
Len we talked about, but then there's a
man named Zachov Sarav. Okay, and he was
Lenin's right-hand man. In fact, he was
the general secretary of the Bolshviks
before Stalin. He was extremely co
competent. And then at a very young age,
okay, only his 30s, he dies of an
illness. That's really convenient for
Salin because now Salin can become head
of the organized department of the BIC
party and install all his cronies into
position of power. That's really
convenient for Stalin. But guess what?
1926, head of the Czecha, Phelix
Javinski. Okay, head of the secret
police. He dies as well under mysterious
circumstances. He has a heart attack and
he's also really young. And remember,
the secret police is where the son of
power in government is. And after he
dies, Sal is now able to implant his
cronies, his loyal subordinates into the
secret police. Okay, so all this is like
really convenient for Stalin even though
we have no evidence that he in fact
poisoned all three. It's just really
convenient for him. All right, this is
really weird how this really worked out
for him. We'll never know why. Okay, but
you have to be suspicious. Okay, either
he's the luckiest man ever in the world
or he was or he basically just he killed
everyone in order to amass power.
And in fact he continues this in 19 from
1936 to 19 uh 38 there something called
the great purge which is continued
revolution. At this point in history
what some will do is kill at least 1
million party members. He destroys the
um old guard and he does so by having
the secret police purge the army and the
procra and then secret units within the
secret police purge those guys and then
new units purge those secret units.
Okay. And so on. All right. There are
those show trials where the Bolshevik um
leaders, the old guard um they confess
to being traitors to the regime. Okay.
They um confess to being secret
capitalists. All right. So let's look at
the parts of the Red Army. This is from
Wikipedia. the parts of the Red Army and
military maritime fleet removed three or
five marshals 13 or 15 army commanders,
eight of nine admirals, okay, 50 or 57
army corps commanders, 154 out of 106
division commanders. So what he did was
he he completely wiped out the entire
leadership of the Soviet military. And
actually this piece of fact is what sort
of convinced the Germans to invade in
1941 because they're like well you know
Salin killed off all the experienced
officers and so let's attack them
because they won't know what to do.
Okay. But in fact you can make the
argument and I think a lot of people
have made the argument that this was
ultimately beneficial to the war effort
in World War II. Why? Because you've
removed all the dead weight. you remove
the conservative
uh generals who are not experienced with
innovative warfare. All right. So by
doing this what what sen did was make
the Soviet military more innovative and
more open and more flexible. Okay. And
so I I know this is a hard idea to
understand. Let's just do a thought
experiment to understand this idea.
Let's say there's hundred of you
students and you're shipped off to a
desert island and you're forced to
survive by yourself. Well, I mean, maybe
in the beginning you would struggle,
right? You fight, but eventually I think
over a couple weeks you would learn to
get along and you would learn to survive
on this desert island. Okay, that's that
that's what I think would happen. I
don't know, but I think I hope that's
what happens. Now, let's let's let's
imagine 20 teachers go with you guys.
I'm pretty sure you're worse off, okay?
Because those 20 teachers would be more
intent on maintaining a hierarchy of
things than actually solving a problem.
And so you can make the argument that by
purging the army uh in the late 30s,
Stalin made the Red Army more innovative
and better prepared for the German
invasion in 1941. All right. Now the
show trials basically all the leading
bullshiks anyone who could have possibly
challenged Stalin were arrested and they
confess to being criminals to being
traitors to being spies. All right? And
all of them were of course innocent.
These are loyal bullshiks who sacrificed
their entire lives, their families in
order to ensure the revolution would
succeed. So why did they confess? Well,
this is Arthur Kesler and he wrote a
book called Darkness at Noon, which is
really one of the best books ever
written. Okay, just brilliant. And in it
he profiles an old bullshik leader and
and he tries going to the mind of this
person as he is about to be executed and
he's he's remembering his life where for
the revolution he killed everyone
basically he sacrificed everyone he
betrayed everyone he is guilty as sin
but the moment that he's about to
execute it he confesses to everything
okay and the argument here is if you
spend a if you spend your entire life
doing bad things You're not going to
admit this is all for nothing, right?
He's going to do everything possible to
save the revolution. If that meant
killing himself in order to save the
revolution, he would do so. So, think of
the original sin, right? The original
sin of the revolution is all this
violence committed against civilians.
Well, now this bosik, he is like Jesus
who is sacrificed, he will cleanse the
people of their sins and allow for the
revolution to continue. All right. So
what was brilliant about this is Salin
put these people on trial and he knew
that ultimately they would
confess and this would cement his power.
All right. So let's summarize what we
what we've discussed and think about how
Stalin won it all. Okay. So there are
five reasons. Okay. The first reason is
from an early age he won a charge of
powerful patrons, criminal um um like
mafia bosses, secret police heads, uh
revolutionaries, right? And then he was
actually loyal to them until he it was
no expedience. What's amazing
about silent is he made everyone believe
that he was loyal
to them personally and absolutely okay
that's that's his absolute power. Second
is he always was able to identify
capable subordinates and he promote them
selflessly. Okay, so that's really
important. Third reason is he understand
silence can be more powerful than great
speechm. Do not become too wedded to
ideas and positions and let others
despise you. So Lman Lennin and Leon
Trosky were tremendous orators. Okay,
they were brilliant. The problem though
is that by making these speeches it
increases their hubris. It increases
their ego and it makes them more wedded
to ideas. Salin refused to give
speeches. So you can never understand,
you can never know where how Stalin
thought about things. Okay? That was his
secret
weapon. Also, no one took him seriously.
Right? At this point in history,
everyone thought Stalin was an
intellectual lightweight because at this
point the Bik thought that whoever had
the best theories were the most
righteous leaders and Stalin didn't have
any ideas of his own. Okay.
Shuji retreats are most effective in
times of internal conflict. So
disappearing hiding offends no one and
offers no risk. So another way of saying
this is the secret police always
arrested Salin at a time of tremendous
conflict within the socialist movement.
Okay. So the split between Bviks and the
menix. Stalin wasn't there. He was
arrested. Okay. So that's really
convenient for uh Stalin. And then last
is let your enemies destroy themselves.
Accept who they are and help them become
their worst selves. Okay, so Trosky uh
lost out because Trosky was a was a
tremendous egoomaniac. He pissed
everyone off and Salin encouraged that.
Okay, so just let your enemies destroy
themselves. And this is what he will do
with Hitler as well. And that's how he
won um uh World War II. Okay. All right.
So, um let's let's take a short break
and we'll come back and do World War uh
two. So
um there's no way we can understand how
Stalin was able to defeat the BVIC
leadership and and so very simple
formulation. Lenin Trosky were all
priest okay but Stalin was a spy and so
let's look at the differences priests
have faith and conviction. All right
you're trying to bring God to the world
whereas a spy has multiple
personalities. So silent could be a
different person in a different to to
two different people. In fact, no one
really thought silent was a serious
threat and no one really took silence
seriously. Right? Second is the priest
have something called analytical
intelligence. That's why they're able to
write books. That's why they're able to
give great speeches. A spy has emotional
intelligence. A spy is able to make you
trust him. All right. The last is
priests are concerned with the person of
truth in God. Spies only want power.
Right? So if you think think about this
way, if you look at this formulation,
then the BVIS didn't really have a
chance against Stalin. All right? Um so
all right. So now let's go on to World
War II. And
um there's tremendous debate as to what
happened in World War II. It was a cat
cal cataclysmic struggle between the
Soviet Union and the Germans. Okay, tens
of millions of people died in this war.
It was a uh tragedy. Um so there's
always going to be debate as to what
happened. Why did the Germans lose? All
right. So let me give you my
interpretation. Basically what happened
was this. The Germans had a certain
doctrine of war uh certain belief system
going into the war and they executed
this belief system this plan perfect
perfectly in the blitz crack okay but
when the doctrine of war failed
um they couldn't adapt okay so the
German doctrine of war is called blitz
crack and the idea of blitzk is you very
quickly cut off the head and the body
collapses you basically go in and you
destroy the command and control center
of of the military. That's what happened
throughout Europe in the late 30s,
right? That's what happened to France.
In only about, you know, a few weeks,
uh, Germany was able to cut off the
command center of the French military
and cause the French military to
collapse. But the problem Soviet Union
is that it's
huge and there's really no command
control center. So what was happening
was even the Germans were destroying the
Soviets, they were wondering around the
um around Russia pointlessly for many
many months. Okay? They really didn't
have a plan because the plan was always
to destroy the head of the snake. But if
you can't find the head, you're going to
run aroundly. The Soviets are really
good at fighting a war of attrition,
right? Uh something called a scorch
earth policy, which is how they defeated
Charles II of Sweden as well as Napoleon
of France before. And that's how they
also defeat defeated the uh Germans. Um
the Germans are known for their
organizational supremacy. Okay. But
they're not known for the battle for
flexibility. The Soviets even though
they were losing many battles in the
beginning of the war, they eventually
adapted themselves to German warfare and
eventually they were able to overwhelm
the Germans. And I think a lot of this
flexibility had to do with the fact that
they lost a lot of their ma major
leadership um in the purges. So another
way we're saying this is the difference
between the Germans and the Russians is
Hitler did not purge his military. Salin
did purge his military and that's why
the Soviets were much more innovative
than the Germans in the war. Also um the
Germans were fighting for something
called libons roam. Limbrom means living
space in German. It's basically like if
we are to survive as a German people as
a German nation we need more resources.
We need more land and so we need Ukraine
okay for the espec es especially for the
oil. But the Soviets were running for
their motherland, mother Russia. So they
were much more motivated to fight than
the
Germans. Now um it was so looking at
this map you you'll see two things.
Okay, the first thing is the Germans
were really spread out throughout the
front. That allows for encirclement.
Okay, that allows for the Soviets to
attack them from different angles and
encirclement. That's the first thing.
Second thing is you will also notice
that the Germans didn't get really
didn't get get that far in this war.
They at most got to the outskirts of
Moscow but not beyond. And the Soviet
Union, if you just look at a map, it is
huge.
Okay. All right. So, um this was one of
this is the deadest war in human
history. The Germans sent in um almost 4
million personnel and they overwhelmed
the Soviets in the beginning, but it was
not enough. Okay, 4 million men was not
enough to conquer the Soviet Union. You
needed 40 million and the Germans didn't
have
that. All right, so
um what's a big deal? So the Soviets had
unlimited resources. They defeated the
Germans. This is a big deal because
let's go back to the year 1935. In the
year 1935, if we were to have this class
and we were to discuss what will happen
10 years from now, we could probably
guess that the Soviet Union would
collapse. Why? Because Stalin was
purging all the major leadership of the
Soviet Union, creating a lot of
discontent, um, a lot of civil conflict
as well. If you look at a map of the
world 1935, most of the world was
capitalist. Japan which controlled the
east was capitalist. Then you had the
Germans, the Nazis rising. You had the
English. Then you had the Americans. And
all four of these nations were under
threat from communism. They were
communist subversive in all these
countries. And they were consider major
threat. In fact, in 1930s there's a real
threat that in America there would be a
communist rebellion. The in Germany
there's a failed communist revolution.
In France, in England, the communists
were everywhere. Okay. So these four
nations, Japan, the Americans, the
English, uh the Germans, they all see
communism as a major threat to them. So
we could imagine that they would unite
against Soviet Union at some point to
destroy communism once and for all.
Okay, that's the first thing. Second
thing is that at this point in history,
race science is very popular. Eugenics
is very popular. And guess what? The
Americans, the British, and the Germans
all of them saw themselves as one
people. the Nordic people, the Aryan
race. In fact, Hitler was a tremendous
admirer of the English people. They saw
the he saw the English as brave um as
brilliant as the master race. Okay. So,
you can you can make the argument that
uh the Nordic people would eventually
unite together to destroy the Slavs
which was a major threat to them in
Europe. And the third major reason is at
this time as Germany is industrializing
the Americans are helping
Hitler industrialize. Okay, this is from
ChachiBT. American industrialists
invested heavily in Nazi Germany
particularly before and during World War
II. Okay, this is important. Major
companies like General Motors, IT&T,
Eastman, Kodak, Senate Oil and others
had substantial assets and investments
in German subsidiaries. So these
American companies, the major American
companies of the time was helping Hitler
to industrialize its war
machine. All right? So given all this,
you could imagine that America would
eventually come to support Germany in a
conflict with the Soviet
Union.
So at this point in
history, the Soviet Union, it was unlike
the Soviet Union would survive. Okay.
But then in
1941, Hitler launches operation
barbarosa. Now this is one of the
greatest mysteries
um among
historians. The mystery is this. Hitler
had organized 4 million
soldiers, a multinational force to
invade the Soviet Union.
spies, the Americans, the British told
Stalin,
listen. Um, Hitler's going to invade
you. Stalin refused to believe them.
Stalin said, "Listen, first of all, I
have a non-aggression pack with Hitler.
We're friends. He's not going to invade
me. Number one. Number two is Hitler is
being blockaded by the British. We the
Soviet Union are providing all these
resources, oil, food to the to the
Germans. Why would they invade us? It's
suicidal. And third of all,
um, Germany doesn't have the resources
to invade us. Okay, so Stalin refused to
believe that the Germans would invade.
He believed it was a British and a
fairest British plot to undermine the
friendship between Germany and the
Soviet Union. Also, there were um some
German soldiers who were sympathizers to
communism. They would run away and go to
the Soviets and tell them,
"Listen, we have I have all these secret
plans of this invasion called Operation
Barbar Roa. They're going to come. The
Germans are coming. Be be ready." And
and what what the Soviets do? They shot
them to death for being spies. Okay? So,
Ger the Germans invade and the Soviets
aren't prepared. But not only that, but
Stalin seems to be purposefully
sabotaging the Soviet war effort. As the
Germans are advancing, the Soviets
should push back. Okay. But Sal orders
the army to stay where they are. So they
get encircled by the Germans. And at
this point, the Germans have more prison
of war than they could possibly imagine.
Millions and millions of Soviets
captured in the first months of the war.
It is a complete disaster. for the
Soviet Union. And so everyone's like,
Stalin has gone out of his mind. First
of all, why wasn't he ready for Hitler's
invasion? He refused to believe that
Hitler would invade. Second of all, why
didn't he give his generals authority to
run the war in the way that should have
been run? Why did sudden interfere and
destroy the Soviet army in the first few
months? Okay, these are the two major
mysteries
of Operation Bar Roa.
Okay, I know this is gonna be
controversial, okay? But I'm gonna make
you this argument. Stalin purposefully
did both things. Stalin purposely let
Hither invade and Stalin purposely let
millions of soldiers be captured by the
Nazis. And you're like, that's
insane.
Well, guess what
happens at this point? Because the Nazis
are destroying the Soviet Union, the
Americans come in on behalf of of the
Soviet Union. Remember, at this point in
history, the Americans think they're
going to go go to war against Soviet
Union. Okay? The Americans want to ally
with with Germany. But because the
Germans are about to destroy the Soviet
Union, the Americans can't let this
happen. If the if Germany destroyed
Soviet Union, Germany would the German
science, technology and organization
would have access to Soviet
manpower, oil and food. Germany would be
invincible. So the Americans step in.
But but but but look, let's look at what
the American contribution of the war is.
In total, US deliveries to USRand lease
amount to 11 billion, equivalent to $250
billion. over 400,000 jeeps and trucks,
12,000 armored
vehicles, 7,000 tanks, uh 14,000
aircraft, 1.75 million tons of
food. The Americans basically
industrialized the Soviet Union, giving
the Soviet Union unlimited resources,
unlimited technology. Why? Because
they're afraid of a German conquest. All
right. from from Wikipedia, roughly 17.5
million tons of military equipment,
vehicles, industrial supplies, and food
were shipped from the Western Hemisphere
to the USSR. Okay? So, Americans gave
about 17.5 million tons of equipment to
the British. Sorry, so to to the
Russians. But guess what? When the
Americans enter the war, they used a
total of 22 million
tons. That's incredible.
The American
army used the same amount of supplies
that they gave to the Soviets. That's
incredible to think
about. Um, yeah, there are millions of
soldiers captured by the Germans. Okay.
And it's a travesty what happens to them
because most of them will starve to
death. They starve to death not because
the Nazis are barbarians, but because
the Nazis had a doctrine of war would go
in and after three months the would
collapse. Didn't happen. Now they're
stuck with these millions of soldiers.
Now they're in trouble because they
can't actually deal with all this all
all these soldiers and they don't have
enough food and supplies to continue the
war. Okay? So these prisons of war are a
huge problem for the Nazi war machine.
And because a lot of these soldiers are
dying in prisoner camps, guess what? It
motivates the Russians to fight to the
bitter end,
right? Um World War II deaths. The
Soviet Union lost anywhere between 26 to
27 million people. Okay. It is the
greatest tragedy to befall a nation um
in human history. One of the greatest
tragedies. Okay. And but okay that is
true but let's look at something called
game theory kind of factual. Okay. What
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you different possibilities
different outcomes. Okay. So let's just
say
um so everyone knows Soviet Union and
Germany is going to go to war at some
point. Okay. It's it's it's entirely
obvious to everyone but and there are
four possibilities. The first
possibility is the Soviet Union invades
Germany and threatens Berlin.
Okay, what happens here? Well, I
guarantee you the Americans come in on
behalf of Germany. The Americans send
their military to defend Germany because
they cannot afford for Europe to turn
communist. Okay, so in this situation,
guess what? Stand loses the war. The
Soviet Union is destroyed in scenario
one. Scenario two, the Soviet Union
invades Germany and is stopped at the
border by the German war machine. Guess
what? Americans still come in because
they cannot afford for Germany to lose
this war against the Soviet Union. Okay,
the Americans still come in, suddenly
loses. Scenario two. Scenario three,
Germany invades Soviet Union and is
stopped at the border. And this is
scenario. The Americans are laughing
their heads off, right? Because fine,
fight it out. We don't care. Okay? And
the Americans are probably going to sell
supplies to both the Germans and Soviet
Union. All right? To destroy both and
eventually they'll come in to destroy
both Germany and Soviet Union. So in all
three situations the uh Soviet Union
loses. There's only one situation in
which the Soviet Union wins. Germany
invades Soviet Union and threatens
Moscow.
Okay, this is the only situation. There
are 10,000 different scenarios. There's
only one scenario in which Stalin wins
the war and he found it and he
implemented it. Okay. But it required
the sacrifice of 27 million Soviet
people, soldiers and civilians. Only in
this situation does Soviet Union win
World War II. Only in this situation.
Every in every other situation, every
other thing that sin does, he loses the
war because the Americans will come in
on behalf of Germany.
And of course this war is fundamental
and it changes the course of history
because without this war without silent
winning there'll be no maong there will
be no communist China there will be no
new China there'll be no today's China
okay you have to you have to understand
this communism was not inevitable it did
not have to happen in fact you can make
argument that in 1940s it was going to
get destroyed by the
capitalists it was only the start of one
world war ii that China was able to turn
communist okay So Stalin changed the
course of human history. None of these
things should have happened. Stalin made
them
happen. And of course we we we today
have Vladimir Putin. And Vladimir Putin
I will argue to you is also going to
change the course of human history. And
this something I will argue to you next
class. Okay. Stalin. So Stalin was the
uber months of the 20th century. I will
argue to to uh you next class that Putin
is really the uber months of the 21st
century. He sees where history is going
and he controls history to his benefit.
Okay. He's going to warp reality uh to
the benefit of Russia. Okay. All
right. So, um we have four great
questions about uh today's lecture. The
first question
is how do the Americans feel about
communism and fascism? Second question
is um the Americans and the British were
very close allies and we know this
through land lease right where the
Americans are shipping billions of like
supplies to Britain for the war effort.
So why did the British hate the Germans
so much? Okay. And the last the third
question is
um what was the sound strategy via V the
Americans? And the last question is
um um in the first few months then the
Soviets were getting were getting
destroyed. So what was Stalin's response
and what did he promise the people to
get them to fight to the bitter end?
Okay, great questions. Okay, so let's go
over them one by one. Uh Americans at
this time in history 1930s the elite
they were heavy Nazi sympathizers. uh
there was an American named Charles
Lindberg and he founded something called
the America first party and and he was
very popular and there's a very good
chance that he would have won uh the um
elections in in America. So American
isolationist is is very is the major
dominant political trend and it was only
when the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor
that the Americans entered World War II.
If the Japanese didn't attack Pearl
Harbor, it would have been almost
impossible to um convince the American
people to enter into
uh the war. Okay, so the Americans were
either well I'm talking about the elite,
okay? They were either neutral like we
don't care where isolation is
or pro-Nazi. Okay, so that was just the
general attitude of Americans in 1930s.
Communism was a real threat to America.
So communism, anarchism were real
threats to the American political system
in 1930s, especially with the Great
Depression. Okay. So does that answer
your question? Great. Okay. Question
number two. Um, so why were the British
so intent on destroying the Germans? In
fact, um, you guys don't know this, but
Hitler made numerous peace overtures to
the British, especially Winston
Churchill. Um and um again I I the the
Germans had tremendous respect for the
British. They I mean like it's basically
the same people, right? Um so why was so
why was Churchill so intent on
destroying
Germany? So um there are different
historical arguments. One argument is
Churchill just hated Hitler. Like
personally he had a visual dislike of
Hitler. Okay, that's number one. Number
two is um the Germans embarrassed the
British uh in the war, right? Because
the British sent this exponential force
against the Germans and the Germans
wiped them out. The the the British were
forced to retreat at Dunkirk. Um I think
for me the best reason is just
geopolitical. All right, so let me
explain what I mean by this. So this is
something called the Mckender thesis.
Okay, this was developed after World War
I. The idea is this.
Britain is a naval power and as long as
it's able to dominate the
seas, it controls the world. Okay?
Because at this time in history, uh most
people are trading through um uh through
sea. So Britain, as long as Britain is
able to control the
uh waterways, it controls the world,
right? But there's a problem here. The
problem is, let's just say that a power
arises within the heartland, okay? And
it could be Germany and it could be
Russia, okay? But it's going to be one
of these two. And if they're able to to
unite or conquer each other, then they
unite the entire European Asian
continent, in which case all they do is
build
railways. And then Britain ceases to
exist as an empire. Okay? So the great
threat is a great power emerging within
Europe, Asia to unite the entire
heartland. And the British believe this,
but also the Americans believe this as
well, right? Because the Americans were
eventually inherent British Empire. And
so at this point in history, Germany was
conquering all of Europe and was about
to conquer Russia. So Britain's um
geopolitical interest was to ensure that
Germany would be uh hindered. Okay. So
um I know in the history in the history
books that you're taught that World War
II was a great conflict between Britain
and Germany for democracy and u human
freedom. That's nonsense. Okay. World
War II was fought primarily between
Germany and Russia. Three4s of German
forces were um directed at Russia. Most
casualties were happening between
Germany and Russia. What Britain was
doing that was vital was blockading
Germany. And as Germany was running out
of food and fuel, it had no choice but
to invade the Soviet Union, especially
Ukraine, in order to access the
resources of Russia. Okay. So this idea
that uh the British and the Germans o
always had to fight. I mean it's it's
something it's something that that that
became mythology after World War II.
During World War II um Hitler wanted
peace. Britain wanted to ensure Germany
could not expand um to the east and
create the heartland. Okay. So that's
what's what's driving British interest
at this time. Does that make sense?
Right. That's
Does that make sense to you to to you
guys? All
right, let's go to the third question.
Um, Stalin strategy for the Americans.
Okay, so what stable able to do that's
different from everyone else is, you
know, if you're Churchillo, you're
thinking in terms of Europe. You're if
you are uh uh Hitler, you're thinking in
terms of like Europe, right? They're all
euroentric. What son was able to do that
made him different was he was able to
see the world as it is. Okay, he was
able to see the Americans. He knew the
Americans would eventually come into the
war. He was able to see Japan. Okay, and
the reason why is um at this time
communism is an international movement.
So he had spies everywhere. So he was
able he basically had the best
intelligence in the world. So he's able
to figure out exactly how these pieces
were going to move about. So for him it
was like okay I go conquer Germany but
then the Americans come in and the
Americans destroy us. Okay. So the main
problem were the the Americans because
the American at this point remember had
the greatest industrial capacity in the
world. Whichever side the Americans
support would win the war. All right. So
Stan had to figure out a way to
neutralize the Americans. And the best
way to neutralize Americans is let's be
friends. Right? Because America's
democracy. If Roosevelt is saying,
"Uncle Joe is our friend, right?" And he
has all these photos in the press of
Stalin and Roosevelt shaking hands,
having these uh these conferences, then
the Americans cannot go around and and
backstab the Soviet Union. And guess
what? After World War II ended, after
the Germans were defeated handily by the
Allies, there were many Americans,
especially uh General Patton, who was
one of the main generals in World War
II. He recognized that oops we made a
mistake. The real enemy are not the
Germans. The real enemy are the
Russians. And uh this would eventually
give us the cold war. So was after World
War II the Americans realized we were
duped. All right. We should not have
come on be come into this war on behalf
of the Soviet Union. We should have
stayed neutral or we should have
supported Germany to maintain balance of
power. All right. So um Stalin just
tricked everyone. that that's why I say
he's the overman. It should not have
happened this way. If you just think
about logically what each party um what
each player in the game should have done
um then the Soviet Union should have
collapsed. Okay, so Stalin was able to
trick Hitler, right? He convinced Hitler
to invade him. He can he tricked
Roosevelt. Um Roosevelt became his
supporter. Okay, he even tricked
Churchill. So I mean I I I I I know this
is not what you're taught in history
class usually, but just look at it like
just analytically, okay? Using game
theory analysis, then you have to
conclude that Salin was the only one who
saw the world globally and was able to
manipulate people to his benefit. All
right? And that's what's then by the way
this this is what's happening today with
Putin. Okay? Putin is the only one who's
able to think globally and he's able to
he's he's only and he's the only one
able to think strategically. everyone
else like Trump um he's only responding
to domestic um issues. Okay. Okay. Does
that make sense? All right. Let's move
on to the last
question. Stalin uh what did he promise
the Soviet people? He didn't have the
problem with anything. He was he was
God. Okay. Do you understand this? He
could do what he did because he was God.
Any other leader who pulled this crap
would have been arrested and executed
for incompetence. only Stalin who
because of the great purge consolidated
power only in his hands. His authority
was
unquestionable, right? He had spies
spying on spies and he had other spies
spying on these spies. Okay, so he
created this like divide and conquer
system within the Soviet Union which
made his power absolute. In fact, you
can you can make argument that he was
the most powerful person ever in human
history because no one could question
his authority. So he could afford to do
this. he could afford to make mistakes
and um and and and and look like a
buffoon because no one could challenge
him. Okay, does does that make sense?
All right. And ultimately the Soviet
people rallied around him
because they didn't want to be conquered
by the Germans. Okay, they wanted to
save their their nation. And Salin knew
this. Okay, this is very famous
quotation attributed to Salin. It's not
true. He actually didn't say this. U but
he could have said this. He said
um 1 million people die in a gulag
that's a statistic okay no one cares one
man's gets run over by a tractor that's
a national tragedy so he
understands intimately how people think
he understands psychology of both
individuals and of nations and such he's
able to manipulate people control people
to his will all right
I think we could add one thing to that
like to your question like what could
actually promise people during the time
of war. And one of it was that for the
first time since he had power, he he
kind of turned on the top of Russian
patriotism because like just with the
Soviet ideology um there wasn't really a
space for a new old Russian identity. It
was a new Soviet identity that was being
created, right? And during the and so
what that meant was that like you close
all the churches you kind ofum rid of
traditional culture and all that kind of
stuff. And during the war, the churches
opened up again and it was it was able
to create a certain amount of unity
amongst the population that was
otherwise kind of divided by ideological
civil. Okay. So um that that's a great
point. Thank you. Okay. So um his major
contribution to uh theory communist
theory is the idea of nationalism,
right? Because what made him different
from Trosky and Lenin was he was only
concerned about the Soviet Union. He
wanted to maintain the integrity of the
Soviet Union whereas Trosky and Lenin
were concerned about international
communism. They saw the Soviet Union as
the little brother um in the movement.
Germany would be the big brother because
Germany had the most proletariat. It was
the most urbanized and maybe the French
as well. But the Soviet Union would be
the little brother to the Germans when
the Germans eventually rebelled and
established the the the communism. Okay.
So Lenin and Trosky were fundamentally
in nationalist whereas um Salin
understood people don't want that crap.
Okay. People want to feel part of a
community. People want to feel part of a
place. And so he heavily promoted
nationalism which galvanized the people
um as Doug says into making tremendous
sacrifices for um during World War II.
So people die not for ideas, people die
for each other and that's what
understood fundamentally. Okay. So yeah,
mother Russia was was his promise to the
people. Okay, does that make sense? Any
more
questions? Okay, great.
So, next class. All right. Thursday, the
grand finale to the course. We've done
the entire human history. Okay. From the
Ice Age when we were just living in
caves. On Thursday, we'll finish the
course with the grand finale, which is
the American Empire, Trump and the
American Empire. Okay. So, hopefully
that will be the best class of this
year. Let's let's let's end let's end
with the best class.